parce que de musique tu te souviens toi
de ta première télé oui
ouais on va passer par ici bas au nom
mais en tout cas le souvenir que tu en
as et son réponse on est excellent
souvenir c'était à tmc à l'époque je
bosse rmc donc j'étais dans le même
couloir et le monsieur qui généralement
présenté l'émission de 19h05 n'a pas pu
venir et on est venu me chercher à la
rescousse on m'a dit tu te sens de faire
la télé je dis bah je vais essayer eh
ben je reste persuadé que oui bonsoir
monsieur s'était pas du tout produit ce
que j'avais prévu de présenter caroline
grimm des données que je vous vois la
super et je me bellemare émission
lagarde tous les goûts tous les hutus
les voûtes à nice est gentil gentil vous
avez vous appris comment bonhomme et
gounod andré est ce qu on peut applaudir
andré si vous voulez quand même merci
beaucoup et j'ai pas tout congé pas tout
compris mais je crois que c'était
principalement des compliments que vous
avez fait à notre mission c'est cela
andréen
c'est gentil merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup andré à très bientôt regarder
bien j'aimerais vous présenter car une
grille maintenant je disais donc un un
nouveau visage caroline la chanteuse mai